so this tutorial
about the ipython interactive
feature and the presenters are Brian
Granger who's a physics professor at Cal
Poly San Luis Obispo and he's been
working on ipython since 2005 and wrote
the first version of the ipython
notebook a few summers ago along with
Jonathan Frederick who's a bad graduate
physics student at Cal Poly and has been
working on ipython for about the last
year so without further ado I'll hand
you over to them thank you very much
fantastic look alive thanks so much
Thomas welcome to everyone welcome to
another PI data Silicon Valley it was
two years ago that we had our first PI
data it was a small event I think maybe
around 50 people we met at Google and
needless to say PI data has grown a lot
in the last two years we're all really
excited about that I'm going to spend a
few minutes talking about a few
practical things related to the tutorial
and then John is going to jump in and
cover some of the basics of the notebook
so the first thing is installation and
the repository for the tutorial
materials and the first link here can we
get the there you go so the first link
there is our github repository that
contains all the ipython notebooks that
will be going through today and you can
download that here as a zip file if you
don't have get installed or you can just
do a local get clone of that repository
and I will well we will keep flashing
that URL up as well the URL is right
here to eternal materials this is it
open and bitrate so we also have the
persistent bitly link there and then the
next thing that we want to do is spend a
few minutes making sure everyone has a
Python installed on their laptops so you
can follow along and to assist in that
we have a few other I Python developers
here there
thomas who introduced the tutorial and
also men is min is right here as well
and so we're going to spend about three
to five minutes with men thomas and john
walk around helping people if you need
help getting things going probably the
simplest way or the way we're
recommending installing ipython for this
tutorial is through Continuum's anaconda
python distribution and if you google
for anaconda Python you can find that
very easily it is a free python
distribution with all the dependencies
you need and there once you download
that and install it it's a double
clickable installer you will need to run
to other things at your terminal on Mac
or Linux or in the command prompt window
a program on windows and that is you'll
need to run Conda update Conda and then
Conda update ipython and if you don't
run that you will be using ipython 1 dot
1 which is an older version of ipython
and contains none of the features that
will be talking about today ipython one
does not have that the widgets and so
you you will be out of luck and so if
you start to use the notebook trying
things out and it's just not working or
things look really different you're
using an older version of a Python and
you need to update and if you're having
trouble getting things installed just
raise your hand and one of the three
will come around and and help you get
that going the probably the simplest way
to double check which python you have
running is to open up a terminal and
just type ipython and one ipython starts
it will display the version number here
that should say I Python 2 dot 0 for the
version that you the updated version
that you'll get with anaconda another
help over here on the right
um another thing that you can do to sort
of the next level of testing is to
actually start the ipython notebook and
the way that you'll do that is to type
ipython space notebook and as of ipython
20 the notebook allows you to browse
different directories on your file
system from the notebook dashboard I can
show you what that looks like let's go
over here so I actually hear it started
the ipython notebook in my home
directory and so I actually look can we
get back to the browser over there
oh right side both sides so when you
start the ipython notebook with the two
da da version you'll actually now see
directories listed as well as notebooks
and so you can click on here's a note
books directory and you'll see that
there's notebooks within that so you can
actually browse your file system ipython
one didn't allow you to browse the file
system this is another way that you can
test to see that you're using ipython
too if you open up the notebook and you
can't browse your file system you're
using ipython one and you want to make
sure to update no there's nothing so the
question is is there a way so if I click
on the home button here is there a way
to go higher than that and there's not
the main reason we made that choice is
for security we want you to be able to
run the notebook server at a particular
point your file system and and below we
don't want you to be able to creep up
and access you know you at sea password
file and things like that more help
while everyone's getting this setup also
wanted to thank the sponsors of ipython
out of PI data in particular obviously
we want to thank Facebook for having us
here on their campus for these three
days ipython these days has a number of
funding sources are our two main funding
sources are the sloan Foundation and
Microsoft so we want to give it a huge
shout out to them we also have money
from the NSF and Simons Foundation and
then Rackspace provides us with very
generous hosting for a number of
different things that we run including
and be view or what we'll be talking
about at some point here all right well
why don't we go ahead and dive in and
all and things off to John one other
thing don't want to forget this if you
go to the ipython RG website on the
right-hand here under the community
section you'll see the help chatroom the
help chat room is a a public hip chat
room and you can enter your name and we
will have different I Python developers
in this chat room so if you want to ask
a quick question there during the
tutorial we definitely encourage you to
do that and you can see different people
joining right now so that that's another
resource that that we will use for help
during the tutorial and with that I'll
hand things off to jon thanks bran so so
everybody is all set up now right it got
ipython two point oh hopefully the first
thing that I want to make sure is that
you have started the ipython notebook in
that directory with the tutorial content
that you download it from that bitly
link that was on the screen earlier with
that you can follow along and all the
exercises will be there
so what what is the ipython notebook
well the ipython notebook is an
interactive computing environment that
allows you to author Python content view
the results in bed rich media and
interactive widgets that manipulate the
Python back end there are three main
components to the ipython notebook the
notebook web application the colonel and
the notebook file itself the notebook
web application is what you see in your
web browser once you start the ipython
notebook server it allows you to edit
the code run code see results of
computations create what is that good a
little bit more so it allows you to edit
code run the code in the browser see the
results of your computations embed math
equations using la tech embed
interactive widgets and manipulate your
Python it allows you to start parallel
computing clusters the second part of
the ipython notebook is the colonel and
with when you install ipython by default
of Python kernels installed and that's
the language that you're using when
you're interacting with the notebook but
there are many other kernels are not all
listed here but these are a lot of them
we have a Julia kernel and our kernel a
ruby colonel a haskell Colonel a scholar
colonel I nodejs kernel and a go colonel
those aren't right now those aren't
super easy to install it's kind of a
pain in the butt to get them working but
with three point oh we're planning on
doing a major refactoring of that and it
should be really easy to install
additional kernels ipython should
automatically detect that and you'll be
able to launch any language that you
want directly
from your dashboard on the last piece
the notebook document it's actually a
flat file it's a JSON document so you
can open it with any text editor and
view the content of your notebooks
notebooks themselves our documents that
are basically an array of cells cells
can have there are four different types
of cells markdown cells raw cells
heading cells in code cells the heading
cells can have different levels and that
that lets you build like a hierarchical
document notebooks themselves can be
exported to static formats so you can
export your notebook to like a plain
HTML document or to a law tech document
and then convert that to PDF and share
that with your friend who doesn't have
ipython notebook installed right now if
you do that widgets aren't exported so
that the interactive widgets that we're
going to see today when you export those
won't your friends won't be able to
interact with the backend obviously
because there is no back end but in the
future we're working on for three point
o a static widget store so when you
export they'll actually be somewhat a
small amount limited amount of
interactivity so let's start talking
about the notebook basic so you have
your notebook server running in the
directory with the tutorial content and
you can follow along the first thing
that you'll see when you start the
notebook is the dashboard I think I
think Brian talked about that a little
bit so I'll just skip through that but
the dashboard allows you to that that's
where you create notebooks it's where
you can open notebooks it's where you
can view the running notebooks there's
actually a running tab and that will
show you notebooks that are running in
directories other than the directory
you're in it shows them in the in the
entire tree and if a note books listed
as running it will have a red button
next to it that allows you to shut down
that colonel when you click shut down if
you're on the running tab the notebook
will be removed but on the main notebook
tab if it's not running it will have a
delete button next to that notebook and
you can actually delete the notebook by
clicking on that it will ask you for a
confirmation and here there's also a
clusters tab on the dashboard so you can
start parallel computing clusters so a
quick overview of the notebook you I
there's a menu that's what you see here
at the top a toolbar and then the
notebook area which is where all of your
cells are listed new to ipython two
point O is a modal system there are two
modes edit mode in command mode it's
kind of like them one mode you're
running commands on the entire document
the other mode you're actually editing
the content of individual cells if
you're in edit mode you'll see a thin
green border around the cell that's
currently selected and if you're in
command mode you'll see a thin gray
border around the cell that's selected
if you're in command mode you don't want
to try the type a bunch of stuff because
things will explode cells will get
deleted and moved and it's just not a
good idea you can enter edit mode by
double clicking on a cell do you see
when I double click on that sell it
unrendered the markdown HTML and code
mirror editor popped up you can execute
the cell by clicking and holding shift
and then enter and that will rerender
the content anything that you do with
the keyboard you can do with the mouse
too so if you are in edit mode and you
need to enter command mode with the
mouse you can just double click or
single click outside of the cell area
yeah that's a good point in the in the
top right-hand corner here you see
there's a small little pencil icon and
that's just an indicator that it's okay
that the tie
that you're in edit mode if you're in
command mode that indicator goes away
you see there's no no indicator there
the idea with the mouse navigation is
that any cell can be selected by
clicking on it the toolbar and menu
items that you use will act on the
currently selected cell and with the
keyboard when you're in edit mode when
you're in command mode there are two
completely different sets of shortcuts
you can view these by clicking on help
keyboard shortcuts that will bring up a
dialog to enter into edit mode you can
highlight a cell click return edit mode
escape goes back into command mode if I
do shift return that runs it and moves
to the next cell you can also do for
basic navigation up and down key but
also J&K work when you're in command
mode you can save the notebook by
clicking s in command mode and change
cell types by clicking why for code sell
em for markdown one through six four
different heading cells and T for a raw
egg cell so moving around the document
using J&K if you hold shift when you do
that or so if you hold was it control
when you do that you can move the cell
do so it's the same direction is J&K
normally does but it drags the cell with
it the code cells we already covered so
there are a couple exercises for you
guys stored under the notebook exercises
document back at the index for this
tutorial and the first one is just
create a notebook and create a couple of
cells that contain simple Python
expressions practice shifting between
command and edit mode a few times going
back between going back to edit existing
cells and then try using time dot sleep
to view the indicator in the top
right-hand corner here to show that the
back end is computing when the back ends
computing you see this will become solid
it'll be a solid circle so just a few
minutes two or three minutes maybe do
that so I'm gonna just wait right here
you
Frank can help ya if you need any help
navigating to the directory with the
downloaded content just raise your hands
if you go to keep calm I'll /a a python
/ ipython okay oh okay yeah somebody
brought it up okay yeah maybe I can put
it on that okay um navigate to the
directory that you download that word so
okay is this inside them okay yeah okay
now do I think on space notebook that
will launch the notebook no no they go
Oh notebook so another
other keyboard shortcuts that are really
useful when you're in command mode a is
for insert cell above B is for insert
cell below that's really useful there
are also in the toolbar here there are
arrows here to move cells up and down in
the plus button here does insert cell
below if you don't want to use the
keyboard shortcuts for that how do you
get into edit mode so I can so here I'm
in command mode if I want to get into
edit mode from the keyboard i just press
return press enter yes if i press escape
it pops out another way to get
familiarized with the user interface
under help there's a user interface tour
and that user interface true will
actually walk through walk you through
some of the user interface things like
this and so that that's another way of
exploring this and it goes through
command mode and edit mode as well yeah
another question
yes yeah the question is is there a way
to insert a cell above other than from
the command line and it's basically the
command line or I guess we don't have in
search cell in the Edit menu we took
place oh yeah it's it's a yeah I please
raise your hands if you have other
questions and we'll have people come
around and I join you want
you
okay I'm going to go ahead and walk you
guys through the exercise if anybody's
stuck so here and this is the directory
where the index is sitting I'll go ahead
and click new notebook and then this
first cell that shows up is a code cell
so here I can type directly in the cell
my Python code so i can do from time
import sleep and then i can call sleep
to to sleep for two seconds and hitting
ctrl enter execute that cell and you see
the the indicator in the top right hand
corner was solid when i did that and
also the a string on the prompt where
the number is it's an asterisk instead
of a number while it's executing so on
to the next exercise go back into that
notebook and add at least one cell of
each type practice the following cell
operations moving up and down cut copy
and paste and merge and split I'll give
you a couple minutes for that so before
you get started with that let me fill
you in you can do cut copy and paste
operations from the Edit menu so there's
cut cell copy cell and then different
paste operations you can also do it from
the toolbar use the scissors like the
copy and the paste operation icons but
you can also use it do it using command
mode so in command mode it's the
standard Keys X to cut see the copy V
the paste so I can ex ii x
and also from the menu you can change
the cell type so if you don't want to
use the hotkeys you can sell cell type
which is one
ok
you
and one of the benefits of command mode
is that for most operations in command
mode you don't need a modifier key so
there's a few where you do need
commander shift but when we say it's
exior V or a or b in command mode it's
just that key it's not command you know
control a or control be or something
like that so it's a very actually very
efficient way of working because you
don't need to modify our keys for most
of those actions okay I'm going to help
you guys with this next or walk you
through this next exercise so I can
insert a cell by going to the menu and
clicking insert and an insert cell below
that creates a cell I can also click be
while I'm in command mode clicking be
will insert a cell below the current
cell I can also click a to insert a cell
above the current cell and I can also
click this little plus icon here in the
toolbar that will create a cell below
the current selected cell so to change
cell mode I can do from the menu cell
cell type and choose the type that I
want this is a markdown cell hello world
I can also do it from the toolbar could
you sell a heading 1 for example but I
can also do it using command mode so
keys one through six are different
heading keys so I can do two for a level
two heading and then one important thing
to notice here is if you edit the text
in the cell and you're in markdown mode
or it's a heading cell when you escaped
out of edit mode into command mode it
remains unrendered so you actually have
to render that cell
once again you can do shift enter to run
that cell and that will render it shift
inter creates a cell below you can also
do ctrl enter to execute the cell in
place or you can click the play button
to execute the cell and move down to the
next cell
Oh move forward ok so I think that's it
for our introduction and we're blowing
through time pretty fast here so I'm
going to hand off the Brian and he can
cover the rich output displayed
framework all right thanks Joe so we
wanted to go through that material to
get everyone on the same page this
tutorial is a little bit of a challenge
in some ways it's you know oriented
beginner intermediate at the same time
we are going to climb very steeply and
by the end being very advanced material
where we're going back and forth between
HTML and JavaScript code and Python and
and so both of your seatbelts
so any time you want to compress the
vertical space of the notebook in the
View menu there you can toss all the
header header or the toolbar so I'll run
in that mode the first part of the the
vision of widgets and I python is
actually something that has been around
from the beginning with the notebook and
that is rich output and the idea here is
that the Python programming languages
allows objects to declare their textual
representations and that's done using
this special double underscore repper
double underscore method and any object
that defines that method when you return
that object from an expression or you
print that object method is called to
compute the textual representation what
we've done with I python is generalize
that idea of a representation of an
object to other formats and ipython to
Otto supports the following formats
listed here HTML JSON PNG JPEG SVG and
actually a PDF as well as of a Python 30
we're really moving towards general mime
types so basically any mime type that
you can imagine a Python object to can
declare how that mime type
representation can be computed and this
is a lot of what has helped the notebook
be used and really leverage a lot of
modern web technologies even without
widgets and so I want to really really
separate these two things that what
we're talking about now doesn't qualify
as widgets we're talking about widgets
we're not talking about the mere display
of a rich output we're actually talking
about a bi-directional communication
between the front end in the notebook
user interface and the back end Python
Colonel where the code is running so in
your mind when you when you think of
rich output think of one way with the
colonel sending rich rich representation
to the browser to display with widgets
you get the bi-directional communication
so you click on a button in the user
interface that can send data back to the
kernel which does a computation which
sends data back
to the front end that's more of what we
mean by a widget and we'll go to into a
lot more detail about that so in this
first notebook talking about rich output
we want to show you how you can leverage
I pythons existing api's for rich output
and the first thing is the built-in
display function display is like print
but for these rich representations and
there's a few important points here
first calling display on an object will
send all possible representations to the
notebook so if you have an object that
has a PNG representation and a lot tech
representation and you call display with
that object we compute both of those
representations and send them both back
to the browser it's up to the front end
to determine which of those
representations it wants to display the
reason we do this is that we want
ipython notebooks to be useful in many
different contexts right maybe you're
starting out you're running something
interactively and in the browser it
makes sense to have a PNG representation
but later you want to convert the
notebook to a lot tech document and in
that context the best representation to
use is la tech this is why we in general
compute all the representations that
enables the notebook to be useful in all
of those different contexts and to let
the context determine which
representation is most appropriate
second these representations all of them
are stored in the notebook document so
when you have an object with a JPEG
representation we encode that in the
JSON we stored in the notebook document
so when you email that notebook document
or you version controlled on github that
data stays with a notebook when you open
it use it in other context that data is
still available in general the notebook
will use the richest available
representation and the richest available
representation is roughly the more
interactive is we consider richest so
JavaScript would be the most richest
down to the bottom would be a plain text
representation images lot tech HTML or
in between I forget the precise order
but I think HTML
above images and I don't remember the
ordering between la tech and HTML we
also have display functions that work
for computing a single representation so
these are display pretty for textual
representations and then display HTML
jpg PNG and we have display objects that
can be used with the display functions
for displaying a particular type of
content so for example here we're going
to say from ipython display import image
and the image object knows how to
compute jpg and PNG representations and
send those back to the browser so here
I'm going to pass a file name and this
is the ipython logo to this Python
object so here I build let's import that
and then if I return that image right
from an expression we automatically
detect the ipython colonel automatically
detects that that object has that
representation we compute it send it
back to the browser and the browser
displays it you can also get the same
effect by passing that object to display
the benefit of display is that you can
call display multiple times in a given
cell it's just like print right you can
call print inside a loop you can call it
inside a function display works the same
exact way an image can also be displayed
from raw data or a URL so here we're
going to grab the Python logo from the
python.org website and we also have an
SVG Python object who that which knows
how to compute the SVG representation so
here's an SVG image embedded in the
notebook you can see what what this
offers it really allows you to tie
together the computational power of a
language like Python with all the
benefits of the modern web right I mean
if you can put something on the page in
a web browser you can build a Python
object that's capable of generating that
content and tying computations to it
there's an important distinction between
embedded and non embedded images
remember I said in general when we
compute these representations we store
them in the notebook document the one
case where that's not true is if you
build an image object and you pass a URL
the data that we're persisting to the
note notebook at that point is the URL
not the image data itself right and so
you need to be aware if you're pulling
an image from a URL by default that
image is not stored in the notebook you
can force it to be embedded in the
notebook down here with embed equals
true and an example of this here is that
there's a webcam that UC Berkeley here
there's a URL that gives the current
image and there's a static version an
embedded version and if you let me see
how are we doing it i guess the api is a
little different than if you give it the
URL it is embedded if you say you r l
equals that URL embedded is false so
just the URL will be embedded if you
give the URL and abet equals true it
will again embed the image data into the
notebook i'm not going to run through
that example in detail HTML so we have
an HTML display object again that is a
Python object that knows how to compute
the HTML representation of an object so
here is a Python string that has some
HTML if we pass that to the HTML object
we've got an object that can then be
displayed and its representation in the
browser is just that exact HTML put in
injected into the Dom of the notebook
ipython also has the notion of magic
commands and magic commands are an
extension to the Python programming
language you know that you're using a
magic command because it will begin
either with a single or a double
sent a single percent is called a line
magic a double percent is called a cell
magic and a perfect example of a cell
magic is this cell right here we say
double percent HTML and again this is
not valid Python code this is an
extension to the Python language that is
on has had since the beginning focused
on efficient interactive usage and it
allows you to just type HTML code in the
rest of that cell ipython also has cell
magics that for a number of other
purposes for example if you've ever used
steiff on we have a double percent
siphon magic that allows you to type
psyphon code into a cell and then we
automatically compile that code and
build a function that you can then call
so it's a nice way of calling other
languages we also have an are double
percent our magic function that allows
you to just type our code into the
ipython notebook I should note that this
is different from our native art colonel
the native our kernel allows you to run
our code without the double % our syntax
at the beginning of the cell so when i
run this you get the same exact thing
you can imagine what the implementation
of double percent HTML does it simply
passes the string to an HTML object and
then returns the HTML representation
JavaScript it may seem a little odd that
we consider a JavaScript to be
representation of an object javascript
is a programming language most of the
other representations are visual things
that you can look at however javascript
obviously can put things on the page and
build interactive and visual elements
and so let's look at that we have a
JavaScript object that JavaScript object
takes a javascript javascript source
code as a Python string when we run it
and then display it we run that code
right we also have a double percent
JavaScript cell magic which does the
same thing
alright and so the notebook becomes a
really nice environment for sort of
playing around with javascript and HTML
where you may want to be pulling data
from Python right here's a longer
example so here we are going to use
jquery's get script function to load
d3.js from a CDN and so we run that and
one thing that's important here is that
when you're writing JavaScript code that
gets injected into the browser into the
notebook like this you can take full
advantage of the various libraries that
ipython itself uses those libraries are
jQuery jQuery UI bootstrap requirejs
mathjax backbone and I feel like I'm
forgetting others but code mirror so you
have a really full featured sort of mini
development environment to write and run
JavaScript code in here i'm going to use
a double percent HTML cell magic to
throw some CSS on the page again when i
run that there's no direct output the
dom elements that have been put on the
page for that style tag aren't
themselves visible but when i run the
following javascript code which creates
other elements in the Dom those elements
will pick up the CSS styling that I've
done in that previous cell so here's
this is just one of the standard d three
examples and when we run that you just
get the d3 rendered in the browser yes
absolutely so you can do that in one of
two ways well really one of three ways
so one if that javascript library is
available on the web you can load it
using jQuery is get script or you can
also load it using requirejs another way
is that I python has directory and b
extensions that's available in your
ipython directory you can put static
files there and then
have those loaded onto your page as well
so there if there's quite a bit of
flexibility there la tech we have to
display objects for putting mathematics
mathematical equations on the page the
first is a math object and here the idea
with the math object is that you pass a
string that has a la tech and the math
display object adds the la tech de
limiters around that in this case it's
the dollar signs and then we bring it
back to the notebook and it's rendered
using mathjax the la tech object has one
difference from the math object in that
you have to specify your math the
limiters yourself and so in this case
the math the limiters we're using our
equation begin and end equation ray and
so here we can run and we see that we
can get Maxwell's equations we also have
a double percent la tech magic that does
the same thing it's important to note
that there's a dip there's two different
ways that you can get a la tech rendered
in the notebook one of those ways is
using output which is what I'm showing
here another way is if I create a new
cell hit em to create a markdown cell
return to edit it here is an equation
and in a markdown cell you can also just
put dollar signs and you're going to get
formatted la tech as well and then I
guess the way that I look at it is when
you're just writing prose and you want
to include mathematics do that in a
markdown cell when you want to
programmatically generate la tech right
where you have some Python object or
maybe an expression tree of Python
objects where it makes sense to
programmatically generate la tech from
that that you want to display that's
where you would use the the la tech or
math display objects audio ipython makes
it
easy to work with sounds interactively
we have an audio object you can pass a
URL that has a an image or sorry an
audio file so you see an html5 audio
player embedded in the notebook the
audio object also takes a data keyword
argument we can actually pass it a numpy
array or a list of a raw audio signal we
normalize that and convert it to a WAV
file and so here's an example of two
different audio frequencies that are
added together and when you play that
you hear the beat frequencies if you can
hear that thank you you can hear the
beat frequencies there Bob just the
html5 by audio support we so the
underneath the hood the audio object is
actually an object that just has an HTML
representation and it's just that yes
for the audio object yes the I that
works for images that definitely works
for audio I I don't remember if it works
for HTML and JavaScript but we're happy
to have pull requests and I do that that
I'm thinking we don't have file support
for HTML and JavaScript and I think that
would be a good thing to add again this
is the web if you could put it in an
HTML tag you can write an object that
has a representation here is a youtube
video object that we have and the
representation of that is an embedded
YouTube video so here's a little video
that has
example of the ipython developing being
used at the first and the first ever by
now suggests on shoes and with a little
bit of trickery you can also inject
local videos and I'm not going to go
through this this example in any detail
here we're base64 encoding a video and
actually putting it in that base 64
encoding in the tag and when we run it
it does indeed work and so you know if
you have a simulation or something that
has a local video that you want to embed
in the notebook that's also possible you
can also embed external sites write an
external website in the context of the
browser is just an iframe and we have an
iframe object and when you run that you
get an embedded web site so here's the
the ipython orgy website i should note
in the the notebooks that you're looking
at here this example is python org and
python.org sets headers that disallow
iframe embedding so that example won't
work just add an eye so it's I
python.org and that will work we also
have a file link and file links object
and that is designed to create a link in
the notebook to another local file so in
this case here when I pass a file name
in this case it's the name of this
actual notebook if I click on this it
will actually open that file in the
browser file links allows you to
basically create an embedded listing of
an entire directory hierarchy and all
the files and those rich output in
security this is where things get fun
the ipython notebook allows arbitrary
code execution in both the ipython
kernel which is where your code runs in
backend and in the browser through HTML
and JavaScript I want to repeat this the
entire goal of the ipython notebook is
arbitrary code execution right take that
back to your security folks until can I
use this web application whose sole go
is arbitrary code execution on our
servers right it's obviously something
you need to be aware of to make matters
worse the ipython notebook has a
JavaScript API that allows JavaScript to
run code in the kernel right what this
means is that if you have a Python
object that has a JavaScript
representation that JavaScript
representation has full access to
running arbitrary code on your system
there's every fault everyone following
this this is extremely important here's
our approach with this one this is the
goal of the ipython notebook we're not
going to hide this right but we want you
to be aware of what you're dealing with
right if you want to think of this as a
loaded gun this is like gun safety it
snowing when the safety should be on it
snowing not to point it at other people
the one promise that we're making to you
is that that won't ever happen when you
merely open a notebook right when when
you open a notebook arbitrary code
execution should not happen the only
type that should happen is when you
click shift hit shift enter control
enter or click the Run button in the
toolbar at that point you should know
that anything is possible right you
could run Python code that runs
JavaScript code that pulls a JavaScript
library that reruns Python code that
does RM minus RF dollar home right but
honestly any time you run Python code
that could be the result of the
operation right that doesn't need to
involve the notebook that is entirely
possible with any Python script or
library you download from the internet
and that you use and so a few important
points one when you run code in the
notebook and that is a deliberate action
on your part all rich output will be
displayed you have to trust the code
that's running to not display output
that is going to do something harmful on
your system when you run a notebook rich
output is displayed only if it does not
contain security vulnerabilities we are
using the google kaha library
me too actually inspect the HTML code
that is generated in output and if that
output is deemed to be dangerous or
untrusted if it has script tags things
like that we don't run it when you run
when you simply load the notebook right
so if you generate a notebook that has
javascript representations and you send
it to a friend when they open it those
JavaScript representations will not run
they're going to have to re-execute the
notebook to get that to show up right
this is this is really important or
there's one other case where you can get
all rich output to run when you open a
notebook and that is if you have trusted
a notebook and the deaf